Anyone who gets to play Spider-Man is living
a dream come true.
Unfortunately, for Andrew Garfield, that dream
was brief.
Why was his tenure as Peter Parker so short?
The answer, as always, is complicated.
Unwilling to compromise
The best characters often come from actors
with a concrete vision, who can turn stories,
experiences, and research into a coherent
whole.
Garfield believed in the power of this process
as fervently as a 25-year-old rookie actor
could.
After the series' cancellation, he told The
Guardian about the work he'd put in behind
the scenes to do right by the character:
“I thought, if I can infuse all this ancient
knowledge and wisdom into [Spider-Man], it
could be profoundly affecting for young people
in the audience.
That was always my intention and what I tried
to do.”
Unfortunately, the studio didn't agree.
The cutting of character-centric scenes, the
promotion of Garfield as a celebrity, and
the ultimate reality of The Amazing Spider-Man
as a blockbuster series made Garfield's high-brow
ideas unsustainable.
He has, at least, made piece with this rift,
telling The Guardian in the same interview:
"What I'll proudly say is that I didn't compromise
who I was, I was only ever myself."
Aiming higher
Andrew Garfield is an actor's actor, and that
means he was never going to be satisfied working
entirely in superhero blockbusters.
Ever since Tom Holland took up the webbed
suit to flip and quip his way through the
MCU's sprawling saga, Garfield has devoted
himself almost entirely to cerebral, arthouse
cinema.
2016 saw him take part in Martin Scorsese's
Silence, in which he played a 17th-century
Jesuit priest.
In 2017, he played a Polio survivor in the
biopic Breathe.
Most recently, he starred in Under the Silver
Lake, a neo-noir that takes his character
across Los Angeles in pursuit of conspiracy.
If the end of Spider-Man pushed Garfield into
this kind of work, its as much a blessing
as it is a curse - and perhaps Garfield himself
feels the same way.
A little too cool
Peter Parker is a consummate nerd.
In his debut in Amazing Fantasy #15, he's
bitten by a radioactive spider because he's
visiting a lab after school.
Peter Parker just loves science so dearly
that he likes to spend his time discussing
the finer points of atomic energy.
Christened "Midtown High's only professional
wallflower" on the very first panel he ever
appeared in, he's a geek before he ever gets
the power to climb walls and swing across
New York.
Sure, The Amazing Spider-Man movies inform
us of Peter's nerdery, but what we actually
see looks very different.
Of the three actors who make up Spidey's big-screen
presence, Garfield is the one whose handsome
looks weren't toned down at all.
Garfield's Peter Parker skateboards and broods
with a charisma that's entirely too cool.
Maguire's Spidey loved to talk chemistry,
and Holland's gets together with his best
friend Ned to build LEGO models of the Death
Star.
But you can't really picture Garfield's Spider-Man
doing much in the geek arena beyond maybe
playing the occasional round of Mortal Kombat.
He's just too cool, and when it comes to Spider-Man,
that's a fatal flaw.
Competing with the MCU
The MCU debuted in 2008 with the explosive
arrival of Robert Downey Jr.'s Tony Stark
in Iron Man.
By 2012, Marvel Studios had pulled its team
together in The Avengers, a blockbuster event
that would usher in what we might just one
day call the "Marvel Age" of movies.
And, oh yeah, Spider-Man was there too.
Of course, with Sony holding the movie rights
to the character, he remained trapped in his
own cinematic universe.
Though Amazing Spider-Man did well at the
box office, the fact remained that it was
completely eclipsed by the other Marvel-based
movie to come out that year.
Plus, the MCU was demonstrating far more staying
power than Sony's spider-flicks.
In retrospect, the writing was very much on
the wall: people were loving Marvel's sunny,
quip-laden vision of their own universe far
more than with Sony's slick take on the iconic
webslinger.
As the years went on, Marvel built up more
and more gravity and Spider-Man, the company's
flagship comic book hero, was pulled in and
revamped by Tom Holland.
There was an inevitability to this process
not even the best movie couldn't have thwarted…
and unfortunately, Garfield's films were far
from the best.
Following Tobey Maguire
Director Sam Raimi's spin on Spider-Man feels
like ancient history now.
But try not to let memories of Tobey Maguire
dancing in the jazz club cloud your mind just
yet.
Instead, remember Alfred Molina's trailblazing
performance as a villain at war with himself.
Remember Willem Dafoe's lunatic glee at being
able to bombard Spider-Man with pumpkin-themed
bombs.
"Are you in or are you out?"
"You're the one who's out, Gobby.
Out of your mind!"
Remember Kirsten Dunst's warmhearted girl-next-door.
Remember the upside-down kiss, and perhaps
above all, remember that iconic train rescue.
At the time, the world loved those movies.
Only five years separate the last of the Maguire
trilogy from the first of the Garfield duo.
In some ways, that's a long time.
But it's not long enough for a generation
to turn over.
Most kids who grew up with Maguire were barely
into adulthood by the time Garfield rolled
around.
Maguire remained an A-list star, rather than
an elder statesman passing down a beloved
role.
It was too soon for anyone to erase the mark
left by the first trilogy from their minds,
too soon for there to be an organic desire
for a new take on an old favorite.
And in the end, that's the desire a superhero
flick lives and dies by.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Spider-Man
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.